five minute challenge five standard
invite game on let's do it
game one of how many I have no idea and
I'm actually in training right now by
training I mean my mouse is in training
so I think there could be a lot of mouse
lips going on
now I'm gonna decline that I'm getting
used to um it's not a new Mouse but I
actually have a new mouse pad which
seems maybe a little silly but it's
actually moving at a different speed
because of the different pad that I'm
using so what I'm trying to say is that
if I lose games I'm gonna blame it on my
mouse I don't know if this is the best
spot for the Bishop but um I'm gonna run
with that okay Knight get to c4 and if
the night plays here I might want to do
night there could be a good one or could
it not so sure maybe I should be playing
a four now I'm gonna play a four I want
to get to be four no be five I mean be
five get rid of the LightSquared Bishop
and this is mine so the be 5 square is
under my control are the Knights gonna
be able to pivot about and caused me
some problems if the night plays here I
think I'll shoot it or shoot it away
yeah maybe I'll shoot it I'll try and
shoo it away right away because
otherwise there might be like a pawn
push in the night this d3 square in this
structure take a good look at it and
want to be extra cautious about watching
out for the d3 squared let alone the
play that black could be having on the B
file now which night to go to this
square I'm gonna go with this one
because I don't know if I really well
the probably wouldn't do that but I
guess I don't want to
what don't I want what am I trying to
say how about I get out of this pin I
lost my train of thought right there I
am oh I was thinking maybe the bishop
will give itself up for the night and in
doing so even though black would
compromise their dark squares on their
Kings side they could maybe have more
influence with the beef I like I think
maybe there's a way to break down the be
5 square a bit easier but my plan I
believe from here should entail playing
b3 ok let's do this first I think
getting the dark square Bishop off the
board is gonna be a good idea so let me
do this first and how to recapture I
think we're gonna have chop chop in the
knight c7 and in the meantime I want to
make sure of getting in some Sun break I
was thinking about an in-between move oh
wait can i take care beyond the night no
let's not do that
let me just mmm
now let's go with this so if something
has to be done with my night ok I think
that that's maybe a slip-up I'm gonna
take here now the King is at least
exposed on the diagonal and I'm gonna
avoid the knight exchange
I am the side that has a material plus
or not a material plus a space advantage
and so I want to keep more pieces on the
board and I think pushing right away or
maybe getting f4 in I'm torn between one
of these two and I believe with the
knight post here I have very little to
worry about let's see if I'm actually
right about that maybe just an immediate
push I'm gonna go with an immediate push
I don't I don't need um the f4 advance
f4 is more of a move like if I really
wanted to get a 5 in but I'm already
able to get e5 in and now this Knight
move it's hitting my pawn
but the other thing is that maybe it's
in some sense out of play because this
is a weak point on b3 and it's never
gonna be accessible to rooks or Queens
pressure now what do I do here
I think I don't want to take an out of
direction can you believe that I'm not
I'm gonna do this I want to I want to
maintain this tension I don't know if I
want to take I don't know if I want to
push I was a bit discouraged from
pushing her here now if there's this
capture and a recapture and rook takes I
can't recapture with my rook because
that right now it has a role of watching
over this pawn I think I could improve
my Queen position
okay the Queen's ready to come up on
this diagonal that could be a big pain
however however this is now dropping
upon now I could take in this direction
land a check and then grab this guy I
think things are working out now hang on
will I end up getting trapped somehow
I'm glad I thought about that because
guess what I would be getting trapped
Queen check rook block Queen takes pawn
rook a6 and guess who's dead the Queen
the Queen is officially cooked if I go
for that line ah what do you know mmm
sneaky sneaky sneaky
my opponent calculate that Queen check
rook here Queen takes pawn rook here I'm
not seeing any square for my queen let's
do this now if I grab here I can run
away along this diagonal so I think rook
right here is best I'm looking to break
open this if there's a is rook right
there where should my Queen go is a
wonderful question that I have no good
answer to what are you do what do you do
what do you do
I'm gonna play here it looks very
passive but I'm gonna do it if I played
to f3 we're pretty no we're not even
with time I'm down in time if I played
Queen f3 I think there could be like
just Queen here I want to maintain the
Queen's on the board and now I want to
get my knight working and I don't know
that I benefit from keeping my pawn
around here actually so yeah let me let
me do this and as a continuation let me
do this my knight I think is better
placed putting pressure on this pond
right here if he go I'll actually both
pawns so there is a constraint now
placed on the black rook my knight is
having I think a bit more of an
influence on the position this King is a
bit more exposed than my own given the
time I'd like to play h3 I don't know if
I could get that end in time I do want
to get my rooks working a bit more maybe
post up on e6 or even Queen to f4 now
converging on d6 + f6 but but and this
is a big pot here oh man oh my trouble
no there's a fork right here
I missed that fork why wasn't i
considering the fork move I have this
for Queen right here is there gonna be
discovered checks you take this and then
can test this file right here pressure
on f6 okay wait I want to do this I
think this is know the night's gonna get
the pond oh okay wait wait wait the
diagonals opened up so what what does
that mean I'm gonna take here and then
try for a queen exchange I'm gonna take
with my rook I want to get there deep on
do I have time 42 seconds my opponent is
a good player good and fast so okay let
me do this and then I get that pond am I
mistaken
do I get the d6 pawn I need to make sure
I get the d6 pawn I think I'm getting it
no matter what should I pre move that
again I have basically a new mouse a
mouse with the new home I guess you
could call it he's uh okay now there's
this and there's no tricky stuff my king
is around to watch over stuff here and
that Knight is a giant pain but I think
I have everything under control I'm
gonna play King here and get the pawn 26
seconds okay now I think my king just
goes into lunchtime about lunchtime mode
ah
lunchtime mode just gobble them up even
if there's a fork at this point I have
everything and I just want to make sure
the knight is dead let me just kill the
night and run with this I'm gonna make
black work a little bit harder to get
that okay hang on just make sure of this
okay I'll be testing out the mouse here
be real happy if I could actually move
quicker and so far it seems like I'm
having very less or very less not as
many missed mouse clicks which is
wonderful I usually end up having a ton
of missed mouse clicks so I might be my
mouse might be new and improved okay
good game down to the wire yes my
opponent was typing that they missed the
fork and you know what you're not the
only one because I missed that too I was
just focused on the pressure points a5
and d6 and okay I guess I had b6 too but
it took me a while to see it so let's
let's go back then Co gambit I guess the
declined version of it
the gist the B file is the one that I'd
have to be most cautious of rook to b8
and Bishop to g7 will be converging on
b2 so this is all pretty standard stuff
although I don't know about about my
bishops placement I guess it's okay if
there is another square it would be d3 I
wouldn't be considering c4 that's the
spot I would like to get my knight too
and this is um I wonder about the knight
move I wonder why I'm the knight
actually went back I don't know I'm not
sure this move I don't know I don't know
what's going on with the knight going
back like that but anyhow my knight this
is a typical journey be very aware of it
take a snapshot of just the pawns alone
from this position a knight on c4 and
eventually in an e5 move I think I went
over this in a previous stream and now
this with this pawn push it really
changes the well it gives it gives a
great direction to the game now because
a lot of the attention will be focused
on b5 since that is the weakness that
was left behind because of the move a5
so push push this is a pretty tight game
my opponent definitely has the right
idea you need to break yeah black
clearly identified the the the glue of
the white position what's holding things
together what's allowing me to maybe run
forward with this pawn push is control
over the be 5 square and if black can't
get through to that point then the
Brooks have no play so that's why I felt
the need to actually avoid the knight
exchange I thought I could be a bit more
of a nuisance and I mean it turned out
to be the case in the game
now once the night is there okay I think
um okay well this is I don't know what I
would do if the Queen played here I
guess there still is an issue about that
b6 square this night coming to c-4 is I
think a difficult one to deal with maybe
at this point in response to f4 is there
the possibility to just take and then
recapture here that's a bit scary to
throw yourself into a pin yeah that's
probably not good so I can't do this
again I'm pretty sure I did the
calculations right Queen check rook lock
Queen takes pawn rook a6 on the dead man
there's no good spot right hopefully I'm
not missing anything on that that was my
thought during the game and still now so
I don't even know where to make a
suggestion did you notice that I'm not
really making any suggestions I think it
was a good game I think actually back
here I don't know I think I'm better now
because of my Knights
when you do a knight versus Knight
comparison so I think the improvement is
gonna be before we even get to this spot
right here I wonder if this is the
correct idea I wonder if things are
already maybe tracing back to this a5
move maybe there's something instead of
that weakness is there really a hurry
with playing that a5 move I guess if if
black isn't cautious maybe I could be
playing a 4 a 5 and then trying to camp
out on the B 6 square with my knight I'm
not so sure that the definitely a very
committal move is this a5 advance and
maybe retreating the knight is just not
a good thing because I think keeping it
around to watch over c4 here is
important maybe a 5 and Bishop to a6
well that that's what was played but
don't do this Knight retreat I think if
there's a suggestion I guess
make don't come back with the night and
also be aware of one other thing on the
black side and I think black did it yes
this right here after black castles
after black castles right here when
there's this castling move the knight
now has EI and this is a I've seen this
many times ei t' c7 and sometimes and
maybe this is this is an idea
ei c7 b5 and you could maybe get that
idea in if your pawn is still under a
six square e 8 c 7 d 5 and from b5
you're looking to plant on this weak
point d4 so this will give me something
more to think about in fact I'm thinking
I actually had this played against me in
a slower game like an over the board
game tournament time controls like a 40
and to sudden-death one when I was a lot
younger and much lower rated but this
this idea of pivoting on b5 having the
pond on you're a pond on the a6 square
to facilitate this Knight b5 post to
then jump into d4 but anyhow enough said
on this particular game hopefully there
are still some things to be taking away
from it